- In the movie, people recognize you,
I love this part in the movie,
when they recognize you,
and all the kids start singing
- Oh yeah,
that really happened.
- The theme song.
Has that ever happened to you?
- When Big came out,
my dad and my step-mom were in New York,
and we went to a really fancy restaurant.
There was a pianist, and a harpist,
and a violinist playing a little music.
You know the piano dance in Big
was to Heart and Soul?
Well suddenly a pianist, and a harp,
and a violinist started
playing Heart and Soul.
- Oh my gosh.
- I said, I think this
is because of the movie.
- Do you get embarrassed
in that situation,
or so you think it's cool?
- It's better than the other stuff
they yell at you.
(laughing)
- Yeah, exactly.
- Wilson!
I get a lot of that.
(laughing)
Brace for impact!
Anything that landed in a movie is--
- We actually call our balls
Wilson in our house.
- There you go.
- We're like grab Wilson,
put him in the car.
- I get a little bit of everything.
Houston, you have a problem!
(laughing)